the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire video today I want
to talk about the night King and why he
is able to ride versary on this became a
very popular topic ever since the night
Cain killed and reanimated one of the
nearest Targaryen dragons
I have already responded to many of
these questions in my comment section
before but I finally want to address it
in a video because someone sent me an
email asking me the question again so I
figured it was time to give my thoughts
on the subject
so let's take a look at the email first
then we can get started the email says
why does nobody think of this the night
King mounts a dragon dead or not a
dragon is a dragon you need the blood of
a dragon blood of old Valyria to ride a
dragon so the night king does have some
Targaryen blood in him this could be a
hint - who the night king truly is the
night king may be the actual Song of Ice
and Fire
he is ice and he mounts a fire-breathing
dragon indefinitely has dragons blood
so the Song of Ice and Fire okay so as I
said before this became a very popular
theory after the night Cain took control
of Vasari on this actually led to many
people believing the night king is one
of the characters that makes up the
three heads of the Dragon for those of
you that don't know when Daenerys
Targaryen was in the house of the
undying she has a vision of her brother
Rhaegar and he says the dragon has three
heads as we all know Daenerys Targaryen
had three dragons and the Targaryen
sigil features a three-headed dragon
plus Aegon Targaryen took Westeros with
his two sisters and all three of them
were on dragons so this leads people to
believing all three of Dany's dragons
must have riders ever since the nara's
heard Rhaegar say this at the house of
the undying she constantly thinks about
this throughout the books this prophecy
comes up again when Daenerys is having a
conversation with Jorah Mormont he says
your grace he conceded the dragon has
three heads
remember you have wondered at that ever
since you heard it from the warlocks in
the house of dust
well here's your meaning malaria on mer
axis in vague are written by Aegon
Rhaenys and Visenya the three-headed
dragon of House Targaryen three dragons
and three riders yes said Danny but my
brothers are dead
Daenerys begins to wonder who will ride
her other two dragons if the dragon must
have three heads
once again later in the same book
Daenerys thinks the dragon has three
heads there are two men in the world who
I can trust if I can find them I will
not be alone then we will be three
against the world like Aegon and his
sisters so as you can see Daenerys is
convinced she needs to find two other
men who can ride her other two dragons
but she doesn't know who these men are
and at this point in the story she
probably hasn't even met them yet I
think most people believe it would be
Tyrion Lannister and Jon Snow
there is evidence throughout the books
that these two characters are secret or
Gary ins but the television show skips
over most of this game of Thrones did
confirm Jon Snow as a Targaryen but it's
becoming very obvious they no longer
want to do the same thing with Tyrion
Lannister they started to lay some of
the ground work for the theory in the
earlier seasons but now it looks like
they completely abandon it by having the
knight King take one of the other
dragons first we have seen other people
write on Danny's dragon with her but we
have yet to see anyone else take control
of a dragon until the night Cain kills
one then reanimates it but does that
mean he is a Targaryen in my opinion I'm
gonna have to say no the night king in
the television show is not a Targaryen
and I say this for a few different
reasons the main reason I say this is
because they did not set up the prophecy
there was no mention of the three-headed
dragon when Daenerys went to the house
of the undying
we never saw Rhaegar mentioned this
either during his flashback scene and I
think it's too late to introduce this in
the last six episodes we have left now I
will say it's not easy to give a
definitive answer to the question
because the show leaves out so much of
the book canon but I will just give you
the reasons why I disagree what the
email some of you may not know this but
you do not have to be a Targaryen to
write a dragon dragon riders could be
found among the dry
'lord families in the Valyrian freehold
when the freehold was still strong the
targaryen were one of these dragonlord
families although they were far from the
most powerful and they were the last
known Dragon Riders to survive the doom
of Valyria and it's aftermath
the Targaryen z' were just one of many
families that were capable of riding
dragons actually a better argument would
be that all Dragon Riders do come from
Valyrian descent one of the best cases
for a nan Targaryen riding a dragon
involves a character who goes by the
name of nettles during the Civil War
when it was decided by Prince to carries
valerian that the blacks needed more
Dragon Riders several dragon seeds on
Dragonstone came forward to answer the
princess call nettles was able to tame
the wild dragon sheep stealer by
bringing it a freshly slaughtered sheep
each morning this allowed sheep stealer
to become accustomed to the girl based
on her description
she sounds nothing like a traditional
Targaryen she had brown skin with black
hair and brown eyes there are several
other examples of non Targaryen riding a
dragon but I don't want to go over each
and every one of them to make my point
now when it comes to the night King all
we should have to do is take a look at
the timeline to let us know whether or
not he could be a Valyrian descent based
on what we've been told the night king
was created when the children of the
forest were at war with the first men
they created him in order to protect
their civilization not only were the
first men cutting down all the weirwood
trees but they were also slaughtering
the children of the forest to the point
that they almost became extinct in order
for them to combat this vicious assault
the children did something out of
desperation which was creating the night
king this took place anywhere from 8,000
to 10,000 years ago during the Age of
Heroes we are always told that the long
night happened roughly 8,000 years ago
when the White Walkers came invading
from the north we can tell just by the
landscape how differently things were
back then when the children captured
this man and turned him into the night
King the Lions beyond the wall were full
of life they were green and lush but
then the long night fell upon Westeros
and the seasons have been all out of
whack beyond the wall has been nothing
but a frozen wasteland ever since now
let's take a look at the
time line once again incy when the
dragons were first discovered according
to the timeline the Dragons were
discovered roughly 5,000 years ago when
the Valerians discovered dragons inside
of a volcano that happened nearly 3,000
years after the night King was created
so him being a Targaryen or a Valyrian
descent is highly unlikely so based on
this I would have to say no the night
King does not have blood of the dragon
now I will say you can poke some holes
in the timeline but until it's proven to
be false I'm gonna have to stick by it
for now most of you should already know
what I believe to be true about the
night Kings lineage I don't think he's
just from the north but I happen to
think he's a stark most likely one of
the founding members of the ancient
house that's why the storks have a
similar connection to the night King as
Daenerys has what their dragons the
Targaryen have an affinity for fire just
like the Starks have an affinity for the
ice the one person who shares both of
these magical elements is Jon Snow he is
the Song of Ice and Fire
not the night king now I'm sure some of
you may still be thinking well if this
is the case then how is the night king
able to fly on Viserion how is he able
to do this if he's not a Targaryen or a
Valyrian descent well I think that
answer is kinda simple as soon as the
night King killed Viserion it basically
put out that dragons life force now he's
under control of a completely different
type of magic which is the night Kings
magic that comes from the old gods and
the children of the forest it's
essentially one of the most powerful
forms of warding just like we've seen my
brain Stark only on a much higher level
we basically saw this put on display
when Jon Snow and company went beyond
the law to capture a white when Jon Snow
killed the white Walker it
simultaneously killed all the whites
under his command the night King is
doing the same thing with Vasari on ever
since vissarion was killed all the magic
that made him a fire-breathing dragon
was gone
now he's only animated by whatever magic
the knight King has which means the
night King doesn't have to have the
blood of a dragon because it's no longer
a normal dragon Viserion is no longer
powered by the same magic that powers
drove gone and Ragle therefore he
doesn't have to be bonded by a person
with dragons
the night Kings magic is able to
override all that because once miss
Ariane was killed it basically wiped his
slate clean as soon as something dies
the knight king is so powerful he can
take control over whatever that is no
matter what type of magic it had
previously basically to sum it up the
knight king is one bad [ __ ]
Daenerys had to form a very special bond
with drag on before she could ride him
but what the knight King has done is
completely different
he basically hijacked vissarion by
killing him first which wipes out all
the previous magic then he installed his
own knight king magic program into his
brain which now allows the knight king
to operate him in his own way but until
we see how everything plays out these
are just my opinions if you have some
other evidence or examples that
indicates I'm wrong I would love to see
them until then this is what I believe
to be true let me know what you think
about this down below in the comment
section everything is open for debate
which I do encourage as long as it's
respectful anyways I want to thank you
all for taking the time out of your day
to watch the video I appreciate that as
always and also want to give a big
thanks to everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel thank you all
very much
I hope you have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]